لا يمكن يكون هناك تقدم على الصعيد
الاقتصادي ممم مشاهد معروف الا لو صار في
حاله من الاستقرار السياسي بشكل او باخر
في دول الغربيه استفادتنا الوضع السيء في
في ليبيا مثلا تركيا استثمرت كثير
بالاقتصاد في ليبيا ايطاليا ارتاحت من
موضوع الهجره كثيرا في بما يحصل دخل
بالتنسيق مع المليون طبعا
هؤلاء داخل ليبيا الدول اللي اشرنا لها
قبل قليل تونس جزائر مصر اللي هي عندها
علاقات قويه دائما مع ليبيا لم تحصل على
اي نوع من الاستفاده من الوضع في ليبيا ما
الحلبيه رايك حاجه
2011 غالبيه الجل المشروعات
الاسكانيه والمركبات الجامعيه
والتعليميه والصحيه كانت متعاقد معها مع
شركات تركيه هذه كل شركات طلعت
والمشروعات خسرت هذا رقم واحد اذا تركيا
خاصره في هذا الامر مش راضي المحيط اللي
حولنا حضرتك وهذا كلام صحيح لما يكون في
استقرار حقيقي في ليبيا
تستوعب الجميع
الجزائريه وبما في ذلك اخوتنا الافارقه
يجون ليبي يشتغلوا فيها يعني ليبيا بلد
قاره وعندها مقدرات معروفه
مش محتاجه لحد يعني لو كان هذا
الحروب ونسلم
لتجاره المخدرات
والهجره غير شرعيه وهؤلاء اغنياء والشاعر
يصبح فقير كان هذا ممكن يكون الحال يختلف
تماما ولهذا عن وجه النداء اليوم من خلال
حظرتك ومن خلال همم هذا البرنامج الرائد
ومن خلال همم قناه العربيه
على مجلس الامن انه هو لازم ينظر نظره يحل
المشكله اما اما اللي خلقنا المشكله في
اساسا هو مجلس الامن احنا لا تورطنا في
هذه المشكله كيف اللي دخل المستنقع ومش
قادر يطلع منه
ايديهم للشعب الليبي ولازم يمنعه حتى في
الانتخابات وبكره نحنا هنعمل الانتخابات
ممكن نتفق عليها الانتخابات اي واحد يدخل
الانتخابات وكان مجالس الرئاسيه الانتخاب
الرئاسي والانتخاب همم البرلماني يجب ان
هو يكتب
بالقبول بنتائج الانتخابات يا قرار عن
مستوى الوطني واقرار عن مستوى الدوري بكره
بعد بكره انت تخرج على على النتائج
الدوليه الاعلام بنفسها لازم نفكروا في
ميثاق شرف اعلامي كيف الاعلان يتكلم بلغه
جديده بلغه الصالح باللغه المجتمعيه بدافع
الناس للعمليه الانتخابيه بدافع المراه عن
المراه
عندنا ثلاثه مليون ناخذ الان سيجري وخذوا
بطاقتهم ممكن لما نفتحه ان شاء الله
في الفتره القادمه تفتح المفوضيه لان في
اجيال جديده ممكن يرتفع الرقم هذاهي كيف
المراه تشارك كيف الرجال يشارك وكيف الوثر
يشارك مش المهم انك انت تحصل يعني بطاقتك
بس لكن يوم الانتخابات لازم تشارك وتكون
رايح مش تقدر تنقذ اهلك ما نربوش احنا انت
عباره عن تنتقد بس لا لا احنا بنمش
هو المشاركه هو الاعلام يكون اعلام شريف
هو نحن نجمع السلاح نجمع المال الفاسد
نقطع من الارشاد نقضوا على المرتزقه